so we're at Fullerton and a Muslim booth
just popped up we already got Samuel
green talking to them so now let's go
see what the conversation is like
so the Old Testament prophets made it
clearly
I said this is this is what the profits
from Moses
are saying that Humanity has failed
overwhelming and that God is going to do
what we have failed to do
everything so when Jesus comes all the
gospels begin with
the quotes from the Old Testament quotes
from the earlier prophets that Jesus is
God coming to us so we see him as well
what the prophets proclaimed about him
is that he is the person
I can actually look who directly who
does he is God perfect
so that's just what it says it's how
every gospel begins from Isaiah 40.
perfect so the fact that he's gone
you can't just say he's got different
because there's any harmful stories
I guess my concern is that I've read
things about Muhammad which I think are
not such a perfect example okay and so
it doesn't you know I could give you an
example of why that wouldn't be the case
so you could say that maybe um somebody
I am the most merciful right but I've
never been in the position of authority
we've never had any choice but to be
merciful to others could you tell to
those who have authority over you so
Muhammad's been here and so it's a
difference when looking at somebody in
authority and how they establish justice
and mercy to somebody who's not in
Authority it's a hard comparison
yeah Jesus Christ for example because I
mean they're coming from that frame of
reference
is a man of authority when you read the
gospels
[Laughter]
otherwise
yes
and so we can look at somebody and say
oh well this isn't right you have to put
it inside like you said the context
um
[Laughter]
when they come to the authority as
opposed to like something like a Hadith
directly but I will say the prophet said
Jesus
to not uh cure young children anymore
incredible here with license so there
isn't there isn't that is true that he
didn't say that but there's also the
example where the women and children
were killed among the polytheists and
the Believers asked him about that he's
like what about the women and children
who are killed and he said they are from
among them
it's like so what they're they're from
them I would say like probably said they
are from them
like no way well
I'll just give you an example I'm not
saying I support this view yeah we live
in America
[Music]
um
so this is the reality awards that you
are going to have unintentional which is
different than harm than saying so what
so like if that's the case then I would
think that Muhammad would double down on
that because they're asking what if
they're like what about the women and
children I would think that he would be
like yeah avoid killing them straight up
avoid killing them instead of saying
they're from among them but you already
said that you admitted he said uh at the
beginning yes yes
no to me it's called No to me it's
contradictory yes so like for me if he's
saying do not kill the women and
children and they say okay well what
about the women and children who will be
killed he says they're from among them
[Laughter]
what would you consider righteous and
just yeah somebody who's kind to the
children kind to every single kind of
children Us in the society so what would
you okay have you heard of his
interaction with the orphan girl
that he cursed girl I know I haven't
okay so there was a there was an orphan
girl uh I can pull up the Hadith I think
it's in bukhar I could pull it up but uh
there was an orphan girl who he ran into
uh and he cursed her saying I hope that
you don't live long she went cried to
her mother and they came back to the
prophet and he's like they're like he's
like what happened you of course you
cursed me you you wish that I that I
don't live longer and he's like oh you
know I'm I'm human I I get angry you
know I lose my temper like everyone else
so what's the context so the context is
are you talking about the Hadith walking
by and he said you know what I'm having
a bad day I hope you don't live alone so
so let's pull it up let's pull it up
surprise
let's pull that up real quick I gotta
find it now see the only reason why I
I'm bringing this up is because of the
comment of him being righteous and just
towards like children and stuff like
that so that just popped in my head okay
so let's see here you know in the Quran
revealed by Prophet Muhammad I think
it's from Allah
coming from a honey forgiven that he
forbade the murdering of you the female
girls because that was accustomed
so the grills uh the parents used to
sometimes he's talking about uh Barry
alive the little girls yeah and leave
them like that and that was something
that was forbidden in the time of the
Prophet Muhammad yeah
I don't think that Muhammad didn't
didn't do anything good right right
I don't think he didn't do anything good
right but perhaps his harm our weight is
good
oh for sure in my opinion yeah in my
opinion yes and from my position right
now yes I could be wrong I could be
educated but from right now what I what
I've seen yes yes
is this it oh here it is
6297 okay
just so you know there's like 50 000
ideas there's so much there's so much
bro no no it's good bro yeah all right
here it is I found it okay so on
sooner.com it's uh 2603 it has a
different numbering
reported that there was an orphan girl
with um Salim
who was the mother of anas Allah's
Messengers saw that orphan girl and said
so it doesn't tell us what he was doing
before I guess
but he saw the orphan girl and said oh
it is you you have grown Young
may you not advance in years
that slave girl returned to um Saleem
weeping um salaim said oh daughter what
is the matter with you she said Allah
Apostle has invoked curse curse upon me
that I should not grow in age and thus I
would never grow an age
or she said in my length of life
um Salim went out wrapping her
headdressed hurriedly until she met
Allah's messenger he said to her um what
is the matter with you she said I was
Apostle you invoked curse upon my orphan
girl he said um salaine what is that she
said she states you have cursed her
saying that she might not grow in age or
grow in life Allah's messenger smiled
and then said um Celine don't you know
that I have made this term with my Lord
and the term with my Lord is I that I
said to him one I am human being I am a
human being and I am pleased I am
pleased just as a human being is pleased
and I lose temper just as a human being
loses temper okay so for any person from
amongst my Uma whom I curse and he in no
way deserves it let that O Lord be made
a source of purification right and
Purity so first and foremost we could
establish Nobody Knows the context not
you or I except for the fact that he
just cursed out so we don't know we
could imagine right so have you ever
yelled at somebody yeah curse somebody I
haven't cursed them no no no not curse
words it's not a curse word no I haven't
wished them was one that did not curse I
haven't wished death on someone yes okay
I don't think he said death either well
he said I would I hope you don't advance
in years that's deadly nonetheless have
you ever said anything out of anger yes
maybe even something that you might have
regretted yes but does that mean that
what you were saying was untrue it was
unjust it's vs it's wrong for me it's to
say out of anger and to try to bring
someone down here the prophets
their right actions their wrong actions
are better than our right actions
meaning that something that's like
permissible for them to do yeah
something that's like low for them is
high for us and so his makam his station
is something higher what I'm getting at
is
what I'm saying is this
you don't know but you're establishing
you just you just said he said this but
not saying why no I I no I know that he
did wrong because even he admits that he
lost his temper but he did not admit it
that he did wrong that's my point so
that's so this because you even said
you've lost your temper before yes and
I'm wrong that you've never no I've done
anything unjustly no no no no no no no
so let me uh let me clarify so what you
what you asked was have you ever cursed
someone before out of your anger I said
no I've never done that I said have you
ever been angry you said yes okay so
let's let's just make sure we're on the
same page yes and I and I've and I've
I've spoken out of anger but every time
you speak out of it just just just so no
so I have spoken out of anger and have
been wrong before yes so that's what I'm
saying so here he says that he cursed
the girl out of anger yes and he's
saying he didn't apologize for it but
what he said is if she didn't deserve it
if people don't deserve it let the Lord
let the Lord bless them so he's not
apologizing guys and for cursing out of
anger but he's like okay well if you
don't deserve it let God bless you
instead and and we're not
going out I'll make two points one is
you've said you've said something out of
anger does that mean that it was by
itself wrong
every time anybody speaks does that mean
it's wrong if they're angry not not all
the time not necessarily so there are
times
there's nothing wrong what they said
but not wrong
so when it comes to someone like a
prophet their deliveries got to be right
as well so he's committing fault because
his delivery wasn't correct so okay that
doesn't mean that he's sort of like an
oppressor or that he's sinful for doing
something like that merely that he could
have done something better so imagine so
imagine this and I like the flow of your
conversation imagine
a prophet someone who is divinely
inspired by God
invoking a curse upon your life
hoping that you saying curse is your age
so that you do not live longer
I am Christian so wait wait just don't
wait follow my line of thinking so we're
so we're talking about a human being
right just imagine the situation yes
you're the the follower of the Prophet
okay he invokes a curse on you you
believe you believe it like he's
divinely inspired so if he curses me I'm
cursed If He blesses me the blessings
from God if he curses me the curse is
from God right so the the thought is
that because the prophet placed a curse
upon me God he's a he's a person
Authority with God so that's the fear
and the Weeping you know she fears that
her life is going to end shortly because
he he cursed her life so the higher
authority would be God does God himself
curse people in the Bible he he condemns
people to death if that's what you mean
okay so if it's good for the goose it's
good for the goddamn so he can do that
Mama can do that so nothing more than
the representatives of God so where does
God tell him to curse the orphan girl
you can't say that every single moment
Jesus Jesus Everything Jesus spoke was
God's word
foreign
not to curse the others but to love them
yes sir and at every single exchange at
every single moment they're getting
direct Revelation I believe when they're
given the word of God yes but not in
this context not every time not
everything they speak right and so yeah
right yeah
I would agree with the Bible he was very
special he didn't have a father
so he was pure so going back to this the
the subject of Muhammad's righteousness
or just I'm just saying I was just
showing this as an example where he was
on the righteous and unjust in cursing
orphan girl's life I would still say you
haven't established that you was
unrighteous so was he right in cursing
the orphan girl's life
in order to establish that we would have
to say the context the context was this
somebody that was
no problem let's say it's a teenager
yeah I'm not even gonna go there with
you because I'm not going to say what it
was you're trying to insinuate no
because no because brother brother
you're saying you're saying that this
determines a factor in determining if
this was right or wrong of Muhammad to
do is if number one what the one of the
reasons you brought up was if the the
person that's being talked to is of an
age where they are responsible for their
actions yes so let's I'm trying to go
with you so let's say that this person
variables which are unknown in this
context okay so I'm trying to figure out
what matters like what why does that
matter context because what preceded the
action and it says he saw her he saw her
that's it that's what it says okay so
you're saying that that literally means
an orphan girl was walking by he's seen
her without any reason said may God
cause you not to grow older according to
the Hadith
that's is it unreasonable for me to do
it I think everybody would agree that's
very unreasonable okay I mean at least
like she stepped on his shoes or
something like anything would have been
better than just nothing just walked on
okay God curses I agree that's very very
I agree that's the point oh my God logic
thank you